thought about o'brien getting fired
yesterday
yeah um you know of course i seen it it
was all over the internet
you know a lot of memes and stuff
included me in my name
but i wish bad on no one you know
everyone you know
in nfl just want to win a championship
and you know some people
you know
aren't able to you know
do those things sometimes as a coach in
certain places you know but
i'm sure that hopefully he can help
success somewhere else
[Music]
deandre hopkins cardinals receiver who
had been a texans receiver who
surprisingly was traded by the texans to
the cardinals back in march and in the
aftermath of the firing of texans coach
and general manager bill o'brien after
only four games as the general manager
there's been a lot of speculation that
it was the deandre hopkins trade that
got him fired that overlooks the reality
that others in the organization were on
board with it or they wouldn't have done
it ownership was on board with it or we
wouldn't have signed off on it period
and we'll talk about that coming up but
the bottom line is this chris o'brien
has moved on and now we are at the
picking up the pieces and or
floating justifications
to the media portion of the post-o'brien
regime and i thought it was funny
yesterday to see the report from the
houston chronicle that bill o'brien had
argued with the likes of j.j watt and
defensive coordinator
anthony weaver during o'brien's final
weeks on the job yeah he probably argued
with them during his early weeks on the
job and during his middle weeks on the
job and he probably argued with someone
every single day of his time on the job
because that's bill o'brien's
personality because news flash that's
what coaches do so don't give me this
crap almost said a different word about
oh oh we had some verbal altercations
with j.j watt and anthony weaver his
final weeks on the job yeah that that
means he was being bill o'brien
exactly that means he's the same guy
he's always been right so don't give me
this nonsense create this impression
that that somehow he was out of line
that's the guy you hired that's the guy
you extended his contract that's the guy
you made your general manager that's
bill o'brien period period so when you
hire him and keep him and promote him
and extend him and pay him and embrace
the good results he brings you
don't try to pin your decision to move
on from him on the idea that he was just
being the guy he's always been nothing
drives me crazier than that kind of
lame-ass justification just just stand
up and say
it was time or
i just felt like it was i'd whatever
just don't don't tell me the guy was
being the guy he's always been yeah
don't tell me that crap all right yeah
i'm i'm god i wasn't sure where you were
going to go with this conversation i
wasn't but yeah that's exactly how i
feel i mean that's exactly right bill
o'brien is a northeast tough
ex-college defensive lineman
you know in your face i don't hold back
any words at any moment
whether you like it or not we're trying
to get better as a football team and
that's just the way it is sorry if
you're too sensitive move on to another
team that's the way he is that's bill
o'brien this is the guy that used to
like miss a tom brady would miss a pass
i was on the field once and he would he
would be on the middle of the field like
just absolutely laying into tom brady
like how do you miss that throw you suck
like he doesn't he almost got in a fight
with brock osweiler at a half time of a
football game he doesn't back down
right or maybe he did right he backs
down from nobody and yeah i don't think
it was like
a j.j watt anthony weaver like tag team
you know we're gonna get in a wrestling
match here no i'm sure billy o'brien
said some things they might have chirped
back a little like hey you know we're
figuring it out or whatever and
tempers flare a little but i don't think
it crossed like unprofessional or
anything like that that is bill o'brien
that is the way he is and that's what i
love about him and that's why they've
been to the playoffs so many times with
teams that weren't that good or overcome
you know one in three starts and do all
those things because his toughness rubs
off on the team to where they fight
through those moments and then still get
to the playoffs and that's all about him
and the attitude he sets within the
organization that's why i think he'll
still be a head coach next year i really
do
and hey i'm not trying to tell anybody
how to do their job god knows i got
enough trouble dealing with my own but
but you you can't well you can because
you did but but i don't think it's fair
to paint this picture
of a guy who all of a sudden turns into
someone with a short fuse and he's
cracking up under pressure
you got to differentiate it from
everything he's always ever done right
it's one thing to say he's had verbal
altercations it's another thing to say
he took it to an unacceptable level that
he was over the top that bill o'brien
who is well known to have a fiery
personality and to be in the face of
coaches and players alike right went too
far in his recent interactions you know
he brought someone's mother into it i
mean give me something
that makes it different yeah than what
it's always been otherwise it just
continues to be
confusing
and i don't under i don't understand i
know texas fans are like what's not to
understand he sucked well
look i and and you know what chris this
is what happens this is why the broncos
fired john fox i think this is part of
the reason
you you get too close and you don't
deliver it's better to not even get
close
i think it drives fans and it drives
people in the organization crazy to be
in the mix every year but to never get
yourself
to truly yeah the highest levels of the
league right and it just and and you and
you and so you eventually just say
enough i can't take this anymore i i
can't i can't take being
in the neighborhood i want to be in the
house yeah and and i think that may have
been uh what ultimately contributed to
cal mcnair deciding to move on it just
drives you nuts when you're you've got
the general map but you can't find the
treasure right well yeah
i mean i hear you you're right fans are
that way i can be that way totally you
know the the the thing i'd say to that
you know is more of
billy
it's it's really like a gift in the
curse kind of scenario i mean the the
problem is he kind of got expectations
up because he won with teams that really
weren't playoff football teams and then
he went to the playoffs with him and
it's it caused a self or a you know this
this sense of like oh we're pretty good
we're only a quarterback away
and all of that to where no you're not
only a quarterback away billy o'brien
had been making chicken salad at a
chicken you know what those first few
years and the team wasn't as good and he
was always patching it up and doing
those things
and it finally caught up to them you
know it finally did and especially with
him being the gm and maybe making some
questionable moves that way too that i
just think about brought the bright
lights on the situation even more um and
and to me that's where it went or at
least the way i look at it but
uh i will continue to say
i think billy o'brien is a really damn
good coach and i think i would be i
wouldn't be shocked if he's a head coach
for a football team going into the next
year and i wouldn't be shocked that next
team that he coaches for he's really
really successful especially if he can
get the front office
the way he wants it somewhat new
englandish which he never got in houston
and that was an issue from day one when
he got down there
and you know a firing guy after only
four games gives him
extended time
and it lets other teams know
much longer
in advance than they would have known
that he's going to be available right
yeah we had that conversation about mike
mccarthy because there was an argument
disrespectful to fire him with four
games left well if you're gonna fire him
anyway number one you give yourself more
time to go out and look for a
replacement without doing so behind the
head coach's back while he's still on
the job and secondly it gives him some
extra time to get his ducks in a row if
there's a job he wants to pursue and
there were jobs he wanted to pursue in
that hiring cycle the year after he was
fired so uh look you got
every team out there now fully aware
that bill o'brien's available here is
jj watt from yesterday
talking about the interim coach romeo
cornell along with some sound from the
guy the oldest coach in nfl history now
romeo cornell who's taking over for bill
o'brien here it is
we uh right now have a uh a fresh start
and we're we had a good practice today
and we're looking forward to
jacksonville iraq's a great man i mean
i've been around iraq i've said before
many times you know i was fortunate
enough early in my career to have wade
phillips as a d coordinator and then i
got romeo canelo as a defensive
coordinator you know two absolute
legends of the game guys with
unbelievable experience and knowledge
insight and uh so rack has a ton of that
he's seen a lot he's been around a lot
he's been around great players great
teams he has rings um
and he has a positive air about him he
has just the
kind of a jolly nature to him and so you
can't really help but smile when you're
having a conversation with iraq so it's
i'm looking forward to seeing what he
can do and what he brings to our team
and uh it should be fun
well i hope our attitude and energy is
different uh and then i hope that our
performance is different um i mean you
know you're not gonna come in and put in
a new offense or a new defense just
overnight uh because it takes time if
you're gonna do that so we're gonna have
to work with what we have and then try
to get
our players to uh to play it better than
we have been playing it and more
consistently
you know what we see from time to time
when there's an interim coach the we
talked about this earlier in the week
the players buckle down the players play
harder there's a bump that comes from it
because the players realize they could
be next if and when there's a new coach
who comes in other than the interim
coach now i don't know that romeo
cornell is going to be a candidate to be
the coach beyond this year but the
players don't know that and that could
coax a better performance out of them
over the course of the next 12 weeks if
they indeed respond well and if they are
concerned they come next year they may
not be part of the team chris yeah well
i mean hey the you know the the eye in
the sky doesn't lie and and these
players no matter what the circumstance
is
if you're a free agent or anything
that's got a you know a fancy contract
your team other teams are still going to
watch the film and they're not going to
go well i wonder if romeo cornell or
bill o'brien's coach in this game you
know so you better be on your game and
there's no you know you don't know that
if the next head coach he might keep
romeo cornell around too to be on the
staff to help out in some way be on the
defensive staff to where if you want to
give up on the year or do something
stupid now he could be there and tell
the next coach hey that guy he's a piece
of crap he'll gave up on us he quit on
the football team get him out of here so
we'll see what kind of energy it brings
to this team there's a lot of pride
watson watt you know
they got guys who certainly are a little
are used to winning and aren't going to
go down without a fight here but they
just got issues on their team all over
just the way the team is built and i
don't know how much they can overcome
you know just with a change of attitude
and things like that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports